[Music]
got a watch tomorrow night cuz Odenkirk
and you and Bob and Bob Odenkirk used to
be a writer on Senate live when I was
there and it was it was there was and
spin smile a smile and a guy named Greg
Daniels that's right there was and and
there's I called you the boiler room
boys we used to and it was so handed
over to the boiler room boys he'll
sprinkle some fairy dust on yeah we were
four nerds you know in a little room at
Senate live in the late 80s early 90s
and that's our favorite host of SNL and
you would come in and you would at 4:00
in the morning it'd be like get the
boiler room boys and we'd come running
out what do you got this up for me come
on you know I did a character and a
premise yeah give me a character in a
previous that would be like we had
old-time typewriters we smoked a cigar
no bad in there bad you know speaking of
TV in the old days a first time I saw
you and a lot of people was in bosom
buddies yeah it started in television I
remember seeing that show and
immediately like a lot of us were like
that's a funny guy but then you
transitioned into the movie business and
that's got to be a different completely
different style of that well a year of
unemployment help not an awful lot right
I cancelled bosom buddies I came in in
February of 1982 right and I didn't work
for about a year and then I had met some
of the people on happy days and and
nobody else would make this movie called
splash and so I had a I had a meeting
with Ron Howard and Brian Grazer we all
just kind of like quasi Young Turks and
they ended up making that movie but it
was tough because I was still operating
on all of the skills that I had learned
on the TV show which is at the
read-through on Monday you must kill
they hand you a script and you've got to
like get huge screams and laughs so
you're working it really hot yelling
your lines you know hey Henry where's my
chubster
you know that's my favorite stuff like
that what are you talking about you lost
my chopstick so we had her we had a
read-through for the movie splash and
this had Daryl Hannah and John Candy and
Eugene Levy oh I was and I was I was I
was the lead who was in love with Daryl
Hannah the mermaid and at the
read-through at Ron's house it had like
every department head there the first
the DP the all that and some executives
from that and every we were there
they're like 30 people there we sat down
and we started to read through and I was
thinking that boy I have I I have to
score cuz otherwise I'll lose they won't
cut to me so I gotta be very funny
so we're reading through it and none of
the lines were comedic lines you know
they were just straight lines and John
got laughs and and and Eugene got laughs
as they had comedic or head to head
comedic roles and I was just trying to
say lines were not funny and afterwards
Ron came up to me say I know what you're
doing I know what you're doing I know
what you do okay it's okay I know what
you do when your test score you try to
score you think it's funny to try to
score your job is not to score you tell
us not to score you're not mean for they
ton because your job is to love the girl
you need to love the girl all right
that's your job and I just said are you
gonna fire me because of this no no no I
will fire you my dad I was there I was
worried that I the second theory you
know that the chops of doing a show like
Bosom Buddies which was all like you
know laughs and me and Peter Scolari
started finishing each other's sentences
yes yes yes that's a third week of
working together I always thought if I
when I cuz the movies is such a
different business I've always thought
if you had a movie and for some reason
someone made the horrible mistake of
giving me a cameo I'd come in and I'd
like look at the camera and do the crap
that I do on television right away and
yeah suddenly people were like I'm not
watching captain Phillips and who's the
ass background you can't do any of that
so this is why you're gonna be at this
desk
okay